okay for those joining this livestream
this is a continuation of a series of
meetings about the calculus of
annotations for things so let's try to
summarize where we got to last time okay
so we've got things
ok so case 1 there's the annotation
things that can have annotations inside
them okay and that includes things like
image things like audio etc okay and for
that we have the notion of annotation
information and annotation rules correct
right Emma okay so there's annotation
information and annotation rules and
annotation rules generally have the
feature that they are of the form where
arrow what is that correct
okay so um well when I say inside them I
mean that can have annotations in their
wrappers okay
another case is things that have
annotation in their elements okay and
this relates again to missing and things
like that so an example of that would be
um you know the list one two and then
something that says annotated bla bla
bla bla bla bla
am I making sense that make sense to
people
yep okay so then there are things raw
constructs
that need
an outer annotation wrapper I believe
see this is the analog so this is the
analog of annotation information because
it is a whole object annotator right
you
since so an example of raw object that
need an outer annotation wrapper the
most quintessential our case is
annotated string
Suns to people why is it friend to
annotated I'm sorry
why is there so I wasn't in that they're
in prison meeting so okay yes you is
that this is aware error what case where
are Oh what so you can absolutely say
annotated but this is saying that there
are inner annotations in the string
you said I'm saying
so whereas here we would say audio of
raw audio
, annotation rules arrow blah blah blah
sir I'm saying where are our what in the
second case what would we put annotated
food for which for things that have
annotation in their elements yes the
what yes just the what
well no no that day yes that's just the
what that's the thing and that's the
what right because we'd only just say
where it is we don't need to tell it
where to burrow to put the thing because
the thing is just sitting right there
and similarly here we could say audio
raw audio
annotation information arrow what makes
sense do we also want to support
annotated of audio
which potentially could then fill up the
annotation information or stay as is
yeah well okay so that's a question
right right right
annotated like if it's a list of rules
then you understand that it's a local
thing and it is just a neither lease to
rule it's a global connotation oh yes
yeah well look the question of annotated
string
right I mean so the question is this
annotated string okay that that I think
that's still a detail let's keep going
on the main main issue here
okay so
okay so here look at this you know we've
got a classified image picture
annotation information class our dog etc
okay so annotation value okay so now
we've got the functions that act on this
stuff
so we've got annotation value
which pulls out annotations somehow
you
and then we've got this horrible
business of the annotation calculus
okay so let's review what cases we have
not covered I mean I'm not super happy
with this yet but let's at least
consider what we haven't covered and so
on okay and also how this relates to
things like missings
right so how do we how are we going to
cover missings in images
shoddy
I'm not sure were you thinking about
some kind of an annotation with a what
that says missing that's what I'm
thinking maybe I mean the alternative is
okay so let's make the analogous thing
for missings okay um
okay so four missing we have V well in
it
things that have annotation well as
their elements or something okay so for
missing we have things like this and I
think we also have an option missing
values don't we don't we have a missing
function of things
no missing missing data rules
and we have let's take a look at what
the missing stuff is
what is missing strain
okay missing behavior
that's totally weird thing um
you
okay so so again
okay so how are we going to represent so
for example images how do we represent
missing stuff in images
we I don't know if there was a meeting
attended you had already that meeting
about I remember seen that in the
calendar because we had certain options
that we discussed and I don't know what
has been discussed already with you so
much to say because right now we in
surely correct me if I'm wrong but I
think in numeric array we do not support
any non numeric value like none we don't
in image we don't asthma obviously so
like the point is like if you want to
store efficiently missing information
for a big number of pixels we may use a
mask like another Rory that contains
like a binary array was last night or
response arrays yeah they're not making
them okay so for a small okay for for
you know the best way to do missing so
far is with a mask right and either a
dense or sparse array I would say that
goes very well with annotation
information the other option is if we
want to use a notation rules if we can
express the mixin value missing values
as a region that is our where and but it
really depends if we can express our
where with the region if not that it
becomes kind of Impractical as jewelers
okay so let's let's look at that I mean
so we could imagine I mean okay we could
imagine that in principle we have an
image arrow
well this makes any sense but I mean we
could do something like that
you
I don't know if that makes any sense I
don't know image seems a bit we have a
specification that if we can express it
as a region then I think of it makes
more sense
well okay either way it doesn't matter
whether it's an image or I mean once
it's geometry okay so let me just
understand something we've got
[Music]
Oh what was I gonna say um masking the
way that masking works explain that to
me where can I put masking is it an
image operations or can I put it in
damage itself operation processing
option it's what it's a processing
option like filter BC Mitchell
yeah or measure this okay so if I say
for example how do I get a nice random
image if I say what's a good image um
you could do random image okay oh yeah
no sunflowers oh for goodness sake that
is that is funny but not useful
you see picture open anymore or
something like that should work
mangog image angle picture picture of
how
great look smart so for example if you
want to find the maximum of this image
you could do I don't know let's try
let's try that I mean this my was
thinking Blair is not gonna work
but it's real asking arrow disk matrix
of 40 or something
splatter saw okay so what would work
just do a disk well Blair doesn't work
but do something like image a ploy no I
well okay that seems very very
complicated okay go ahead then do a 1
minus hash to negate as a function and
then the masking right okay there we go
beautiful let's say an owl in the
crosshairs or something okay that's nice
okay so there so now we could imagine
um I mean we could imagine something
where we have some kind of missing data
arrow
I mean I think the annotation thing is
more general and I don't think you know
the annotations on the image
should be able to be any reasonable
left-hand-side
given the type of data that you're
dealing with so for example in this case
if that is a 1 0 you know
pixel array so be it
but I don't quite sure what we're going
to do with those annotations on an image
what are we going to do with them
if we say annotation value what will it
do or do we not even want that you mean
how do we take them out yeah well no no
no I mean I'm saying annotation value if
if the image look let's say that I
carved out the ears of the owl okay and
I put an annotation that said ears on
those ears right then I said an
annotation what's that can you hear me
yes okay I don't think we have all the
use cases for what image annotations
will be but one very common is medical
yes okay fine which is a good case of
ears and eyes and so on right so an
image cases will we presumably want
something all right so then if that's
true what would an annotation value do I
mean we want highlight image to be able
to highlight by annotation right
for instance yeah and ideally something
like dynamic image to be able to create
an image revalidation okay well okay
then we want another case we want is
want a way to to show explicit labels
for annotations with an image now that
might also be true for graphics right we
can imagine doing doing an annotated in
a graphic
could be an option of an annotation as
well
right right right but this annotated
might want to display with call-outs for
instance yes something that I've been
wanting to add to highlight image but I
wasn't sure if I should have spent
development time doing it myself or if
we want to have general generic call-out
support for graphics because right now
it only works in plots in in plotting
functions we don't have a call-out in
graphics as far as right because it's a
way different problem so it's it's
substantially harder Cola and graph what
what are you talking about sorry Cola
and graphics is substantially harder and
we solving case by case for
visualization so it's a whole different
you know right right to do it for
generic graphics as opposed to a
structured visualization like list plot
exactly
so but I mean clearly
you
so I mean if if we do this
oops
okay that's very beautiful
so you're saying Roger that the graphics
analog of that why why is it so much
harder because and well like I'm calling
out a polygon is obviously a different
thing from calling out a point well yeah
exactly and that's that's basically what
we solving case-by-case on and in these
are highly requested things nuts and the
visualization team doesn't really work
on graphics you know graphics is
something the front-end team works on
first of all um graphics are we in fact
solving this problem of call-outs and
graphics or not no we're not we're
solving it for visualization that can be
another project and that means that we
take away your visualization capacity or
try to solve that or we need to solve it
in some other way so we have a
visualization team you know and we have
a graphics team the visualization team
works on visualization surprisingly
enough I wonder whether people like you
to Anne and John's group would be in a
position parthia you're you're here um
could you just okay
any capacity to do it but I'm not even
sure I mean well do you want to comment
on this John has been paying attention
here oh hey I've I keep talking and no
one hears me that's why I needed to quit
and start audio again to be heard
yeah the is your question about the
capacity or about the problem itself
both I mean the problem itself
algorithmically seems to have been
solved for visualization by the
visualization team for at least certain
cases that a true statement Roger right
and there's gonna be many more cases
solved for 12 but I'm just saying that
they're yielding not superfast and we
have to kind of work no no I understand
but where were the graphics people to
take your algorithmic solutions and flow
them into graphics I kind of I think
that it would not be a performance level
that we would like okay that's the
problem so it's our graphics is already
way too slow you know you know I you
know I think that well the issue is this
I mean okay look if you want to call out
and we simply don't have call-outs the
performance is infinitely slow that's
true but a I'm just thinking it's not
something that you just dump on a team
and hope that it's a zero cost solution
it's it's a major cost solution and it
probably won't be very satisfactory well
I mean look things like labeling by the
way I mean labeling obviously works
naked in the following sense if I say
one labeled two three you know four
three that will work like that
right but if I were to say and if I were
to say tooltip there it will also work
I'd think why didn't that work
look John
it should I was that not working
yeah I this is version 12 by the way
that might be a bug yeah it's something
is wrong there okay
I'm by the way John for it's worth there
also are if you're looking for version
12 bugs
there are cursor bugs this this cursor
click situation is wrong here I sorry
don't know what do you mean by this
cursor click situation I'm clicking
right now and it's still and it's
staying as an arrow cursor oh okay
shouldn't be okay this isn't gonna this
is this is a horizontal Aybar cursor in
this situation I didn't go to the
insertion cursor this is the first time
scene of this problem I've been having
this problem all day and maybe a
particular build so I got the
tooltip' on a day I'm gonna have to go
proto um so I can you know concerning
labeling you know we did a thing for
labeling but but it you know it's like
something that looks beautiful and seems
to work great until you try to really
use it in anger and then you find you
know various issues with it some of
which are ridiculously hard all right
sorry so label in which I lay blame
things on graphics yes does it look at
all yeah it works and in fact it's used
in some in some graph stuff but but this
is why we have graph outputs that are
bugs in my group instead because because
there are some cases where it you know
where it doesn't work so well so if I
say like point no you don't get there
through the labeled rapper no this is
this is something that is there is not a
top-level syntax for and it's because of
issues of fragility and design I mean I
think we all agree that this will be
highly desirable if we could do it do we
agree if we could do it yeah I'd be
great and the reason we can't do it is
because it's because you want to do it
well you know so you know like you want
you want your labels not be clipped at
the edge of the graphic way harder than
you might think
you want labels to not overlap other
labels yeah you want labels to not
overlap interesting contents yeah okay
okay all right okay let's go back yeah I
mean by the way this really should be on
our long-term list and I should put this
on the on the long-term list and this is
definitely not something that my group
presently has the resources for I
understand and right now we're juggling
you know the world of 3d graphics that
can't seem to standardize on anything so
right I think they very well
standardized on chaos young yes yes I
have stand corrected
um okay okay so let's come back to our
original discussion okay so there's a
question of how we represent a
standardized way to represent missing
stuff in an image for example or for
that matter in a string I mean what if a
string like for instance a genome a
genomic string has missing values in it
string is a more extreme case because an
image is case one things that can have
annotations in their wrappers by making
sense yes um okay so first question is
so in the annotation rules here that we
want so first point is the sub sub case
here is where should be able to be
anything reasonable okay which means it
could be part specifications it could be
an image map it could be a region
geometry anything else
that could reasonably be single
positions which make maps two points
single positions maybe it could be an
interval
no image but right for other objects
right so let's just make a list of
things that can have annotations in
their wrappers okay image audio time
series
to review well that's some small
difference right okay what else
graph which already has that properties
right yes which we want to get rid of
and replace that with annotated
it's Charles here yes I'm here
so for graph you need annotation value
don't you because you have a property
value mechanism don't you yes we have
property value set property of most
property on source a whole set of
operation to male properties
sorry what did you say oh you got a set
property thing set property of a move
property property lists which provide a
list of property because there is user
defined properties beyond this okay so
you should set a notation instead of up
front
okay so that then you say for graphs you
would have a set annotation that right
and the set annotation in the graph
would say set annotation of the graph
and then it will be a node spec node how
does it work Charles so currently small
a Elise Kraft common old or edge and
then property has this circuit argument
or additional document but so a more
replace part kind of syntax would say
given the graph this node well I see
you're saying I mean okay so hold on
want one thing would be something like
this and then the property which is of
the form you know prop named arrow value
is that correct yes okay so
and how do you remove an annotation we
have a form of annotation where you
specify that tool so do the car for the
car plus vertex or edge is it set or I
mean really set you know to my mind this
should be add annotation because it
isn't really setting and the sense of
set I mean it should be if it's going to
be something like that it will be add
annotation move annotation that set it
you can use set to set the value for a
variable when it doesn't have a value
yet or when he has about it already
doesn't really matter no I know that but
set suggests a side effect l value type
thing which is not the story here this
is merely returning a graph with the
thing added
correct correct but we made it insane
because you also have that l value
aspect in half which you know property
value with L value so that's why we use
is set instead of just how does that
work so essentially you can't do I
really hate this I mean that design was
just awful um just the design work its
provide to functionality we need and I
know but it's awful it doesn't fit in
with tons of other stuff I you know
somehow that design snuck through at a
time when I was not paying proper
attention my mistake but anyway okay so
you claim that you have an L value form
which is different from this because
this is not the old value form this is
taking the graph and returning a new
graph right yes okay so you claim you
have a forms in which you say in which
you have an annotation value L value
gosh this is horrifying okay which what
you're saying is annotation value of
graph common node somehow equals comma
prop comma prop name equals value
and what does that do what does it do
there's no L value here what does this
do essentially what we wanted for
performance and efficiency to be able to
set it in place that's it what the heck
is the semantics of that but there's no
name what's the name of the thing that's
set but is set here is do classes
actually the same dissemble is not this
to craft I say do you know the instance
of the class is the dissemble so you do
set for party value okay so you say ay
ay ay equals graph of whatever exactly
so you're saying I say something like
this okay whoops let's do I don't know
what we want to do five or something
okay so there's our graph and now what
you say is that I can say property value
of that graph comma what say X label I
don't know which which vertex am I
talking about
oh right you can't essentially put it in
a list so you can do a a comma one and
let's say vertex labeling for example
arrow automatic can I do that what will
that do now it should be that vertex
labels okay
I don't equal automatic here yes like
that right oh boy
that is really horrifying that's really
upsetting it's really horrifying do you
think people use this a lot yes
isn't the center is kind of similar to
what you do in Association and in part
though it we have it over the system I
mean this yeah I've been creating
presidentials what are you talking about
this is normally this would be a you
know the function property value
would be it's just really awful it's
really awful
this is also the same thing that you
know use current value in the front end
what yeah and Robert what weight
property value oh boy that's that got
all tangled up with entity properties
and so on as well Stephen if you do part
a comma one equals something he's going
to walk the same way I know it's like a
symbolic part yeah I know
yes except that that was a design from
like fifteen years ago
that never got finished and this is not
it because this isn't a symbolic part
this is a very specific thing that is
setting you know this isn't a pure
symbolic pot that's doing some
complicated thing inside that graph
structure okay so we're gonna have to
rip this out and we'll leave the
functionality obviously but we can I
have to actually fix this I don't know
yet but certainly this idea of
properties is going away you know we've
got that four entities we don't want to
have properties this just doesn't make
any sense at the very least you know the
nomenclature for this is annotations not
properties but in any case I mean with
this idea how does that apply to for
example images I mean would you expect
then with something like this to be able
to set a value for a pixel in an image
that's not how we do it right if you
want to change like my friendly owl here
if I want to change it to you know how
do I reset the value of a pixel in the
ow
[Music]
replace image value or replace pixel
value or just replace image rally do it
will return an image with the pixel
replaced is not in place give it the
same disk matrix and then arrow
see they write whatever you want yips I
don't think we get this matrices here
it's probably goes with the list of
pixels I I don't know if I got around to
update these to do the general thing but
if you right you can put like in my by
the way that just jumped um John if you
care when I deleted that the the scroll
position jumped sorry I didn't the
screen
I was just deleting around here and the
scroll position jumped to the bottom of
content okay um oh boy
so oh great Jose by the way is asking a
question well let's see um maybe we can
see if Jose can join this meeting he's
asking he wants to use missing values as
well okay he's got missing values for
geo elevation data and he wants to use
it as well
let me go get him okay
there's okay so so he's pointing out the
background
deals with missing in some way in the
image case is that right no ideas with
transparent pixels which is which is a
which is no cheaper way of doing missing
yeah furthermore it's it's also mean
it's also taking a real value so what it
is if you have out four point five you
eats half missing maybe yeah I
understand
so so that's another this is a case we
need to make a note of here right so in
images missing is a bit like
as parent
or partially transparent
pixels by the way Charles what drives me
crazy about this property thing I mean
the functionality is quite sensible at
some level I just can't stand the names
and the whatever it may be just a
problem of a single word which would be
good um okay so what what's the right
way to do this do I have to say image of
disk matrix do or you can specify an
interval a list 10 through 20 no we've
we've we've okay great chip off I'd the
owl or something
you
okay
so
what's the point okay so that's the way
we're doing it in so that would be the
way that I would expect this to work
some kind of replace you know
if a child trust me correct me if I'm
wrong but they think that you lose so
much in efficiency by doing that because
you were to recreate a graph object
every time but look look look look
that's you know there's a zillion ways
to deal with that that don't involve you
know you know you do not have to well I
don't know how you're storing these
graph objects and whether they're I mean
clearly with an expression you know
right Charles can you say something
useful about that so sure I mean we like
you point out I mean we can always find
a way to implement it efficiently with a
you know a function I could please CAF
replace property does that shouldn't be
a problem right well okay so so fine I
just think the semantics are forcing
something like this is just wrong but
anyway okay but that let's let's go back
to okay let's loop back I don't like the
number of mechanisms that we have here
it's too many all right so let's go
through again what we're talking about
so we've also now got this notion of
annotation add annotations remove
annotation so this is sort of indirectly
addressing annotations which is as you
say like a symbolic part system
look hi you're in the middle of a whole
discussion about annotations and and
missing values and so on so remind us
what your use in geo elevation data is
yes so the problem with the elevation
data is that sometimes we ask for
elevation in our region and say we have
elevation for land but not for the sea
and so we have to return something and
we we want to return there is why don't
we have valuation I'm sorry why don't we
have elevation for the ocean I mean but
I mean it's either both amatory or it's
the surface elevation right yes but for
example okay another example is we have
a region which is rectangular region but
then we project it and then it has a
different shape so we want now to
represent these empty spaces I see
but I'm sorry the the G relation for
ocean we do have that don't we we have a
data of lower resolution for the
bathymetry for this ocean floor exactly
is that what we're returning we're not
returning the ocean surface well the
idea was what happens if you are
interested only in the in the area of
land or having the data which is the
original data right I I'm sure that this
is really irrelevant to this meeting but
I think geo elevation data should have
an option to determine whether you want
the surface of the ocean or the seafloor
I mean because that's the other case
you're describing the main the main case
is like in your image we have background
and then we can say if if the world is
in the bond projection so the background
is going to be right because it's
outside the world so we have the similar
situation to return
elevation for the world some right but
I'm just suggesting I mean I don't know
we can we can you know include ocean
floor or something I don't know
something like that
okay but but let's come back to this so
let's review again what we've got here
we've got so we've got these cases of
add an annotation which is really weird
but it's a convenient thing to do if
you've got a bunch of annotation rules
for an image you don't want to have to
take the thing apart you would prefer to
just say I mean maybe this is a penned
annotation
you
annotation append annotation delete
so in other words then what you would do
is you would say annotation append of
this image and then you would have a
aware of what does that make any sense
and that would return an image again
with the new annotations and with it
with additional annotation rules so one
slight difference and the current thing
that we have implemented in audio which
is I mean as I said multiple times just
a short ride to see how things work
so we built a little bit on the property
values so each of the annotation has
labeled in addition to aware and what so
when you add a limitation or a movement
on tation you can specify which one by a
label okay
so that if you have to overwrite an
annotation rather than having to delete
and then append a new one
so you're saying there isn't the notion
is an annotation replace it's an
illusion set I would say and you said
the particle is proton to that label and
it's not a set because not an in-place
operation no so what we use is just
audio annotate a specific function for
audio no I understand that so what
you're suggesting is that
if okay so this is replace not by we're
not necessarily by we're but perhaps by
tag correct
okay so let's look at the other cases
here okay so
in this where our what how would we put
a tag in there so one way of doing it
would be grouping them by tag so you
have tag one goes to work one goes to
what one except they're accepted at time
two goes to a similar thing that would
be one approach okay hold on so so let's
look up here at you know we're saying
annotated of x-bar
speaker is Bob emotional state is happy
you could argue that the speak the keys
here are the tags and values of their
values the what the what
well okay but I mean in this case what
you be saying is um
okay so let's let's look
the full thing so this would then say
you know annotation rules arrow and then
it would say here let's say interval
from some time one to time two
speaker is bar but emotional state is
happy yeah so the what I'm saying is
essentially equivalent just inverting
there are a lot of things having the tag
to be D key no there's two different
things you might want here one is
replace Bob by Robert
um
you
or
[Music]
another thing you might want to say
replace this interval by it by some
other you know say actually at the end
of that interval he was unhappy
yeah so the I guess the advantage of why
it makes sense to have x as the first
one in this hierarchy is that say for
you you might want to annotate the
speakers so you have a speaker stag the
under neck collection of intervals in
volume you might want a transcription
tag and then intervals in alright so
what you say is just for them
differently no no I I know but but but
but so but then I don't think the
replace is the place where you want so
then it will be different it will be
speakers arrow and then you would go
time time interval unless the where
comma 1 where goes to what yes okay but
is this what you meant by the tagging
yes okay so what do you mean by
replacing it so then you're replacing
that whole bulk tag thing is that
correct yeah exactly and you can specify
for example a deeper structure up for
example you can specify speakers comma
where for example
okay so you're proposing that in
annotation replace that one could say
you
um
[Music]
in some way or another hear speakers
comma time interval arrow blah crap
I'm obviously crazy I mean in other
words
you know I have to say the correct way
to do time intervals will be with some
kind of event series here I would think
the problem is it doesn't really support
intervals
it should weather an interesting comment
on our live stream is why not use a
fifth color channel for missing
seems more like a hakjin a solution I
agree we also support its transparency
it's a hack - yeah but it's a common
hack that everyone uses yes still
creating a lot of issues every time we
try to deal with that properly we yes we
spend a month before the summer trying
to understand if we are being consistent
enough with alphatron and handling and
it's it's a rabbit hole like it's really
a bad luck to use it to store
information it is like when if you take
to use like a specific color value for
missing data I mean you can do that but
it's really a bad luck no I understand
but the point of a fifth color channel
is you're not doing that you've got
another channel I would rather keep it
as a separate option on their image so
if you have a gray scale with the like
three yeah okay yeah you're right let's
go with with the gray value the
transparency and the missingness yep
that's crazy well I mean okay so okay
let me let me make another suggestion
okay right now our image data is a an
ordinary tensor so to speak
what if image data could have an
association as its backbone so in other
words where was explicitly named you
know red color channel blue color
channel transparency so in other words
what I'm suggesting depending on how
interleaving is set right there depends
which way around the entry every could
Unix I understand I understand I'm just
asking in principle how it should work
right I mean you could imagine I'm not
saying it's a good idea but you could
imagine something where you've got I
don't know which way round people
typically have the interleaving set how
do they it's it's typically triples
right yes right so I mean in principle
those triples could be have an
association in them
I mean in in terms of the right way to
do it this is not an obviously stupid
way to do it in terms of how the code
actually works
it's hopeless right now first statement
what do you think this is not a good way
to do it even if the code could work
this way yeah it's gonna be very
inefficient to analyse everywhere well
okay yeah I think it was it's gonna be
cumbersome for for so to operate and I'm
not saying that what we have here in
this in this notes it's less cumbersome
but I think I'm not sure I mean I let's
reverse I'm sure we are not gonna solve
this thing soon yeah I understand I
understand I understand that all right
so let's go back here - okay we've got
these various different approaches right
so we've got annotation information
which is the whole thing annotation
which is equivalent to annotated and
presumably
our annotated
of thing goes to
you know annotation information option
if it can that right yep that would be
nice and I was even gonna suggest as you
say we're proposing a lot of workflows
do we really want to annotate it or do
we wanna just have annotations for the
objects that can store them and then
create more of these objects like the
annotated string or the rich string well
you know whatever we want to call it
that can store these options because
there are cases where the thing has look
annotated it's perfectly reasonable in a
time series you want to be able to put
that in there and then maybe have the
thing you know I think this is what we
discussed last time the thing Auto
convert to annotation rules right for
entry of the thing it is convenient to
put the symbolic wrapper around a single
element
right and then in other cases that it
can't put it on their annotation rules
or information it's symbolic right
there's never any choice probably won't
doing much with it but it won't have any
choice I mean it's it's then just
I'm wondering whether we need to
functions if you need annotated as just
an inert thing and annotate as the thing
that tries to dig it down and you know
do an actual evaluation into something
else
not sure why do you think you might need
that
I don't
that we do I mean I'm just wondering
whether there's cases where it's going
to sort of continually try to bury down
as you are trying to work with things or
I see well okay or you know in in terms
of pattern matching you know yeah you're
right you're right okay so that's not
obviously wrong okay to have an annotate
that turns into annotated if it has if
it has two but generally I mean we could
yeah I mean that's a sort of in the in
the concept of that's a last resort it's
true how would you do and usually you
have image that are already let's say
there's no missing value in the image
then you want to add missing values how
would you do that
you'd use annotation rules
and that's an option so which okay so
the way you would do the Hatchin imagine
you rap imagine an amazing image no the
way you would do that honestly that
would suggest that this is called
annotate
yeah
and that in that case what you would do
is you would say annotate the image with
the where is whatever it is you know
disk matrix 30 arrow missing and this is
essentially what we have for audio
annotate this is what I was measuring
before with the addition of this tagging
but as the same mechanism earlier
misguiding there and it could also be
just the words I'm not sure why we
should well yeah a little bit so okay so
in that case the what
is
well okay so this is where it gets
complicated because the what might be
something like you know label arrow
painting or something like that if
there's just the word then it lives you
know notation information if it's if it
has a word it lives in a mutation rules
no I understand that but the question is
will the outer wrapper you make to
insert that could be the same outer
wrapper it seems like it could it seems
like clear yes well I mean aware is
missing
what do you mean no how do you the
problem is if the thing if the payload
if the what is itself a rule
how do you dissolve that grace but the
key of the rule is definitely not where
but what if it is what if you happen to
say three arrow whatever okay
okay yeah I see your point it seems like
a caramel kiss but yeah we have talked
about it I'm not sure there may be a way
to disambiguate it okay
but
and we really need this options or could
we just do everything with annotate what
do you mean plug the first options of
image in image please pay attention yes
I think we need those how would how
would we put the annotations without
that oh so you mean internally I mean we
could have an internal way of storing
things and yeah why not expose it
I don't see why we shouldn't expose it I
mean I mean delay expose how it's
constructed an image and an audio yes
image data I don't know do a suit God
but not really we don't expose the
internal construction but for example
meta information is there
you know I think I mean you can also do
information of image but we never expose
how it's encoded inside we pretend we've
exposed it with image data yeah I don't
really know what the relationship
between image data and what the actual
storage is it so that we pretend it's to
pack to write some kind no no it's a
numeric array it was a row array but
it's that thing but it's similar to like
vertex list for for a graph like Y is
not giving you like the displaying the
full content of the of a construct is
just giving you one specific part which
is in that case a pixel value right
because otherwise we just need is an
annotating to add stuff maybe something
to extract all annotation something to
clear all the annotation and without you
can do all I reckon the only way to
store it meaningfully is effort lives in
the input file and the only clean way
that I am aware of of storing it and
then put firm is to have options at
least for audio an image yeah it could
be communication inside and it could be
its our internal choice if we don't
expose it it needs to be exposed because
it needs to live in the input fur I mean
I mean if you look inside a classifier
there's a whole bunch of stuff it's in
the input form but it's not exposed it's
not documenting anywhere right okay but
okay you're suggesting the possibility
that you annotate and the annotation
sort of vanish into the ether but has
stored somehow and you can get them back
out again yeah and that way you don't
even need labels and stuff I mean if you
can grab all of mean there was a debate
about referring to a specific annotation
by a label which I find a bit weird
because it's not being a lot of label
like there's aware there's a word and
then the label a city to the annotation
in order to refer to
from outside which I find a bit
complicated before it let's try to
you're proposing okay so this is at
Ian's new proposal sorry okay so the
idea here is then that there is a pure
function annotate yeah and this just
adds annotate meditation yeah and it can
deal words or it can be aware what and
any object
okay so - let's say object
this is aware our what etc or just what
and this would return either the same
object if you can allow store annotation
inside or an annotated proper
okay okay so fine it returns an object
which which might in fact use that very
same thing but we might or might not
choose to document or emphasize the fact
of what it's actually doing with
annotation rules and so on okay
something to grab all the annotations
may be called just annotations or get
annotations which is the equivalent of
annotation value I guess yes okay but
but then so annotations there and maybe
it has a selector as well as an optional
selector that's a bit complicated like
how do you well it can have whatever
selector it feels like like that like
for example it could get the annotations
for a particular range of times I mean
that selector could depend on what the
object is yeah right I think exactly was
proposed before I don't think there is
any difference except attorneys saying
we shouldn't store it in an option but
for audio an image we don't really want
to change the structure of an order in
an image then in the only the only
solution is having an option to know a
tennis look the the difference in what a
TN is saying he's pivoting our point of
view not the actual technical
implementation really at the point of
view is
function called annotate there's a thing
called annotations that pulls the
annotations out and yeah what I'm saying
is that this is what we were proposing
before just the name is like different
like annotations instead of annotation
value and unnoted is what we called many
names annotation append set notation etc
accept our deal annotation replace is
something we would then need as well
because it's got to be able to replace
an annotation right okay we could have
something that you know to replace you
grab the rotation then you do whatever
change you want to do then you put them
back in the object but that is horribly
horribly massive if you have a lot of
annotation so you want to change it a
little perp what a confuse addition
replace is that there'll be old can of
annotation and how do you specify one
it's kind of the selector business this
is why we were trying to have this tag
system as well in addition to the where
and what which my opinion complicated as
well yeah I understand but let's go
through this list here and let's look at
the way that we're already using
annotations in graph okay
so let's ask the question does this work
for graph
that's a Charles question that's
effectively set property for graph right
so you can search of the graph which is
in general for cough is not useful
usually set off the property I know but
it's gotta wear so it you you can say
set it for a particular vertex okay and
annotations is property value
effectively correct yes okay and okay so
let's look for a string for example okay
how does that Ian's proposal work for a
string so we'd say annotate we've got
our string and then we say so the where
error what might be the interval for
eight is the gene Braca one
saying what does that return
this would be our annotated okay we
could decorate that a little bit more we
could say annotated object or something
or we could have a thing called
annotated string that's specific to
strings
that's what I was proposing for when or
for objects that we don't have a
container
maybe we just introduced a container
yeah or we or we give an error I mean in
other words if you say annotate for
example let's imagine that I did this
let's say I said annotate this number I
think we just give an error
do you agree and I don't think there's
anything useful we can do that I agree
yes now there's a sort of weird up value
case
where we are is there an up value case
where we're saying one two three
annotate for hello
well actually the correct thing to do
here is to return unev al you ate it not
to give an error but just to return an
evaluated because then in this case here
that could perfectly well if you say
let's plot of that or something it could
perfectly well work at some point
I think this is you know the sort of
thing where it comes back to my
suggestion that we have the active in
the inactive thing that you know this
would be you know like tooltip or
labeled or whatever where it doesn't
really do anything until something else
gets to it right the visualization code
looks at it goes ah annotated of
something and I'm going to do whatever
with it or the typesetting comes across
it and says this is gonna map into some
functionality in the you know when it
gets displayed by the front end or yeah
but you don't need something that's
trying to bury in that case second case
that Savannah's up there doesn't make
sense
probably debts should still return an
error message there is no part four
through eight in that number who says
that's a part yeah right because I mean
in general this is going to be you know
you're gonna be able to say annotate
time-series blah blah blah you know time
one comma time too
you
that makes sense I think what we sell is
that the where should be any object that
makes sense or could be a part of the
object fine but okay so the question
here is is this useful is this kind of
inner annotation useful
or is it only useful to put annotations
into wrappers
see I have a feeling that in like in a
time series I mean I think it will be
useful to be able to enter this I agree
I guess in different places we'll find
uses for this okay but can it be the
same function annotate you know in other
words if this thing is a time series
ultimately and one value is annotated
there is what goes graph do now with
this if you have if you add a style to
one node of the graph does that stay in
place or does it get moved into the
property list of you know style tool T
annotation right so it then moved out to
a a centralized option basically Charles
is that right
why so we move it back to a property no
no wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute where does it get put if I put
these things here do those get moved
into a central option which says the
labels of every node or does it get
localized as a wrapper around the node
just look at input form of a down down
move to a central which you know that
excellent last option I see okay okay so
set it here but I mean if I'd set a
specific vertex label how would I set
the label for for the thing number four
how would I set the specific vertex lab
offer so if you use property values
you'll you know it you know in at least
put you know a a comma comma four and
then the value
funky okay okay okay I understand okay
so in the case of the time series you
have as well we'll just move their
annotated four into the centralized
place whether that's they exposed
annotation room yes right but the toe
does this want to be can this be that
same function annotate or should it be
annotated I think it should be annotated
I kind of think that's safer here's
another case which I mean I don't think
necessarily forces it one way or the
other but it's worth thinking about is
what happens if you have annotate of a
list of the list one two three right now
does it try to bury down into the list
and apply well it could yeah I mean two
goes right I mean it could but you know
you may not want it to you know in
certain circumstances and so that's
another reason for having dinner the
inert version
right so that's this right that would do
that is that is that what you're a major
imagining something like that yes but
yeah okay all right so let's look then
at so we would need annotation replace
annotation
delete probably well clear annotations
to clear everything I don't know yeah we
might want to full clear annotations
well actually probably delete
annotations would be the natural thing
but but in this case if you want to
remove a single annotation you could
probably have a
you know you have to have a right hand
side that represents that it isn't there
question so if you change the value that
is annotated would it change the
annotation well that's a really good
question right your replace part right
that's that's the calculus about
annotations that is a whole big topic of
its own let's not open that now well but
just just let's just raise that for one
second the annotation preservation
function sounds like some kind of mine
is that we have time series insert so I
can insert a value at a given time and
you know if so what happens is this
annotated as the whole value or the
value it's four and I change the value
for and I keep on notation and what if I
insert you know and I try to insert
another annotation in yeah so this does
apply in the annotation propagation so
in this so you could envision having an
option in time series itself that says
annotation goes to none or inherited
that controls the behavior so you are a
totally new time series do you want to
inherit the annotations that you already
have do you want not inherit do you want
to do some custom behavior and I think
some of this is already present with
graph is it - ah puppies all right so
for the twelve you're actually
implementing inheritance of property in
cough which is based on you know user
workflow requests so you can't take a
function American build a calf and then
you do neighborhood half and then we
preserve the property appropriately and
is what you are building by knowing the
prototype yours is not they say calculus
of you know a notation that is more an
inheritance of annotations based on
operations okay so you're saying in this
case there's an inherit
I've annotation but the problem is it's
not obvious inheritance about
annotations eg and graph okay but it's
not obvious that these annotations are
divided divisible so to speak
see what I'm saying so in other words
let me give an example so let's say that
a here let me give an example within a
graph okay um let's say that you your
graph represented a mechanical linkage
structure okay and you are labeling a
sub graph as being you know the stable
core of the structure let's say right
right with me so far
so now let's imagine that I pull out one
of the members of that you know one of
the edges in that stable core do you
really want it to still stay it's the
stable core so what I'm saying in other
words it's like is it an intensive or
extensive quantity or something in other
words because it one thing it could say
is oh those are the those are the beams
that were added by you know Bob's
construction company right and clearly
you take out one beam the other beams
were still added by Bob's construction
company what but okay so in our case I
mean we more focus on the case of what
flows that maybe provide ability easy
you know I need the ability to actually
you know move those ones or set them or
a load inheritance was essentially that
because there's no like you know like
train your example there's no ginnifer
so this you know I know that but a bit
so we need to distinguish between
annotations that come in clumps versus
annotations that are basically intensive
quantities such a distinction is 25 more
yeah so that way for us from I mean the
user I mean from the whole quest form
user which was so that is you know those
that an efficient Ranieri test
depend on the functional kind of it's
kinda understand I think I've requested
this thing myself in other words if you
make certain nodes red you don't want
the redness of those nodes to disappear
when you extract a subgraph right um but
not depending on the Christian do you
want the cord you to be maintained or
not depend on all that yes yes I
understand shouldn't disappear for sub
and sub graph extraction um okay but
should coordinates be preserved but then
maybe a property that's not redness
should disappear so what are all the
weight or the capacity you know
different way or the flow of a
user-specified property right so so what
that means is that what you're saying is
that these operations you're doing so so
you can either put the information into
the operations or you can put the
information into something and into some
okay so there are two ways to do it
that I would imagine one is in an
operation that is done say what prop
what annotation should be preserved
that's case number one or when the
annotations are inserted say what
operations should preserve them those
seem to
the two obvious possibilities in the
second case who should say that right
now that time have this strange side
effect on minutes which one which the
second case I mean it's hard to predict
I mean it's um yes I agree I agree so
this is probably better especially
because we could have user custom
created functions or operations right
that that we don't know the exact no but
then right but in that case it's not
going to be preserved by default unless
you have an option that says you know
annotation preservation function yep I
think we should have that and which way
round is that is the annotation
preservation function in that's in an
operation or is it in the the operand I
think in the operation okay yeah I mean
from from my experience in terms of
annotation preservation function so you
know if it's in function in our sense of
functions that mean you actually have to
define it and is a non-trivial thing to
define these operations okay so wait a
minute so look what we basically want
them what you're suggesting is we want
an annotation preservation option okay
and so then so then that could have a
value there are lists options to pop an
attends to preserve somehow I don't know
how it says that though so you know in
our case what what happen is that is
depend on the function right so
currently the proposal essentially we
you know we have such an option but if I
recall it you can say automatic
inherited or not right so those are kind
of the three default one and if you use
subgraph you know we will tell you
exactly what you know if
say automatic what we preserve if you
see in every that we you know we copy
all the property coming from the
original cost well okay so let me let me
specify some things so if we said all it
means preserve everything if you say
none nothing obviously an automatic is
certain properties thought to be useful
for that operation and what we had
thought for audio when we were thinking
about tagged annotation is that you
could actually give it a list of
annotation tags so speakers speaker is
preserved all right all right so a list
of tags so tag one tag to UM
okay but so what does that look like in
terms of the structure so in the
annotate where we've got where arrow
what that means in that case that that
would have to say that it would be
tagging so we would be saying the where
well how does this work how does this
work you know look if you want I can
show what dhikr the current
implementation that we have looks like
if that would help
I guess so yes fine go ahead and share
if you want okay like you just leave the
second is you want to send me the
notebook I might do it on my machine
just so I'm sure but also statement I
really think we want the preservation
function or something like that because
both where's and what's we may want to
modify as we are moving them to the new
one think about audio pad and we have to
add an offset time often so so the the
structure is like a different rather
than what you propose we were discussing
with staggers to where so what else
I have a slightly more complex
structured with some additional metadata
field which can for this purpose can be
completely ignored so in this case you
have a tag and then this is the main
data which is a list of in this case
where and value and what are in the same
Association they could be as easily
separated this is just a convenience way
of storing them so you have a tag and
then a where and what and you have two
levels of tag
even beat and then you've got data so
forget the data level this is just a
convenience to store some additional
meta information which I'm completely
happy to drop it this is just how we're
yeah this is just stemming from some
existing this is what this is basically
the form I was describing it's a tag
arrow where our what exactly exactly and
to set it you can set the whole the
annotation for the whole audio object
which will then go in the annotation
rules option and you can inspect it with
annotation value but you could also set
some just the time you set the tag TS to
this value for example mm-hmm and it
passes that automatically etc etcetera
so this allows you to change just just
the annotation corresponding to that tag
and so you can have this and here I am
not attending any orientation and just
changing the notation correspond IDs and
forgetting it you have a similar kind of
park-like specification so you can
retrieve a single annotation forget this
this data level is really ugly should
really be killed and then you can
extract a single part of the annotation
now the thing that I added you are
discussing is some selection mechanism
so in this case you could select
annotation from all tags from a specific
interval or a list of intervals or a
specific time or a list of times for a
specific annotation rather the normal
notation for all of the previous
electives but you could also define a
custom selector using I mean this this
is you don't need to consider this this
is that the main point here look and we
should wrap up for this meeting that
that
the main meta point here is for audio
you have a certain set of kind of
tagging and annotations that you want
there for graphs we have a certain set
of tagging or is it the question is how
Universal is this what is this a that
aware a tag and a wat yes so that is
there is accurate that is what how this
format works and the work could be
whatever time whatever thing
there's no restriction on the what we
have a restriction on they wear just
because we are dealing with earlier but
I understand but the problem with this
is that the fact that some things don't
need the tags everything needs aware
unless its global and we're currently
distinguishing the global case well
actually Etienne was proposing to not
distinguish the global case in terms of
the original annotate function but then
we were discussing whether we need to
distinguish it in the original annotate
function correct do you want me to stop
shredding sure
you
okay so the question here I mean we
could standardize on requiring a tag for
for annotate no no I think is depend on
the object under use on the workflow
right graph mesh well similar workflow
which doesn't match with what you know
how you clear it on notation in audio
right for a car for example if vertex
annotation weight is a mutation on
coordinate is a notation and you do
shortest part you know maximum flow they
use those a mutation is specific way
yeah so what I'm saying here is that the
for example vertex lhamo could be the
tag of the annotation so if we just be
renaming what is a tag that's a volte
because the vertex of a base Murphy Z is
an option right especially when you're
the validation may seem like as well as
into operation you can do a sub graph
you can specify the vertex level
globally right which is kind of
integrate we do calculus of a notation
we already kind of awfully have that
implicitly even though we haven't seen
evidence of property rights so oh boy
guys this is complicated we're gonna
have to continue it's an unfortunate
this is complicated involves many groups
um I don't know whether there are people
here who feel that they don't need to be
here
I think you know we got a schedule
another hour and a half to talk about
this I mean I think we're gonna get this
nailed I think my prediction okay my
prediction is that what will happen is
that we will realize that annotate
should be able to be given an A
structure whose whose form depends on
what is being annotated so that we don't
have to standardized because I don't
think there is a standardization that's
my prediction
I mean that makes sense you know the
only possible or alternatively the other
way that that this could fall out the
trouble is there a tool okay
in a sense what's happening is
I don't know why I'm thinking of some
crazy thing about fiber bundles but but
it reminds me of this there's kind of a
there's a you know there are things like
the node of a graph the time in a time
series or an audio sequence the position
in an image right those are
on some base space there's something
that live in a I don't know there's
something that have some what can I say
they have you know that I don't know in
it's not quite a manifold exactly but
there's some there's some I don't know
geometrics not really geometric there's
some sort of okay then on the other hand
there are tags and the tags live in a
completely abstract world where you can
just name anything you wants as a tag
right and I think
what we're saying
is that we sometimes want things to have
a sort of spatial localization where I
say spatial in quotes because it might
be time and it might be nodes in a graph
or something and we sometimes want them
to have some kind of semantic
localization with the tag
and sometimes both exactly my guess is
those are not the only categories of of
localization that we want
that is that you know those are just two
cases I claim I claim there are other
cases I don't know exactly what they are
in other words what is the difference
that the the the conceptual difference
between
yeah here's a what is the difference
what is the difference between a you
know the sort of coordinate eyes version
of this yeah some of these are kind of
coordinates and some of them are in some
completely abstract space where you can
just wear it sort of in a categorical
space where you can name anything so the
problem is that there is a bit there can
be a bit confusion between the tag and
the what because you could use the tag
to express what the annotation contains
so there is some ambiguity there well
okay but but okay the what itself could
be an association that you know I mean
so one possibility is okay every
annotation we are currently considering
involves some form of where except for
global annotations correct yes and one
of the things that we had considered
before was that the what was always an
association
which means it always gets some kind of
tag well no it doesn't really get a tag
I'm sorry it doesn't get a tag it gets a
what kind of a thing is this which is
different shoot yeah how to think about
this see I think what's happening is you
know we're basically saying an
annotation can be anything and then
that's on the one hand on the other hand
we're saying annotations have to have
certain properties you know which is
gets us into this calculus of
annotations business
all right we need to continue this is a
different time sadly I'd be happy to go
on but I I know I mean I actually I'm
supposed to do something else and
all right I mean I hope we can get the
schedule but in a few days so we haven't
lost context here um I mean maybe people
can think offline about this problem
I mean of of them you know yeah I mean
see we want to be able to pick pick up
annotations by their coordinate by their
tag
possibly even by their content and this
is why I included that we are selected
with a pure function that gives you know
I understand by concept right I mean
see ya okay look I think the person that
look the two people who have who are
most advanced in this a Charles and
Carlo so maybe we could ask those two to
have a conversation offline to talk
about that they're very different I mean
those are two well developed annotation
systems that are rather different yeah
you can see if we can we can I mean the
proper the GAF one is the most mature so
we can I can make my shelves and see if
we can try to inch the audio one to the
graph one I'm not worried listen with
the graph one cosmetic renaming is not
going to be a huge problem okay there I
mean sound reasonable Charles yes yes
okay all right good stuff thank you all
thanks to people on the live stream and
will continue soon right
bye bye